is going to ruin the clip for the
religious folks but you want to play
this little game of earning it oh God
loves you when you're good you mean like
your boss at Cheesecake Factory have a
God that's better than the boss at
Cheesecake Factory there that's the
language I've been looking for that's a
bit I'm working on so that's so genius I
have to write that down no one ever gets
to the Cheesecake either oh you're so
full I hate when they put the calories
in there cuz I used to get the chicken
and biscuits salads are like 1,200
calories the chicken and biscuits is
19950 calories I'm like that's the day
and I used to eat that and that's the
Rock's cheat day